.
THANKS.
>> Bill: MORE ON THE MIGRANT
CRISIS IN NEW YORK CITY.
FORMER CANDIDATE LEE ZELDIN IN
STUDIO.
CONGRESSMAN, RAN FOR GOVERNOR
AND FAILED BUT RAN A REALLY GOOD
CAMPAIGN AND DROVE A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
QUESTION FOR YOU.
HERE IS "NEW YORK POST," GOT IT.
BRAVO TO ERIC ADAMS WITH HIS
VERBAL VOLLEYS AT THE BORDER BUT
WHAT WILL HE ACTUALLY DO?
THIS IS THE BIGGEST STATEMENT HE
HAS MADE OF MAYOR OF NEW YORK.
>> I AGREE.
INSTEAD OF THIS RED STATE AND
BLUE CITY AND RED CITY BLUE CITY
BATTLE GOING ON, REALITY WAS
EVEN IF ALL THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS BATTLING AND ON THE
SAME PAGE FOR FIXING THIS YOU
WON'T RESOLVE IT UNTIL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION STEPS UP AND DOES
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO SECURE
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT IS APPROPRIATE AND HE IS
RIGHT BY SAYING IT IS ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO RESOLVE THIS.
>> Bill: SOME OF IT RAN
YESTERDAY.
SUNDAY AT THE BORDER HERE IS
ERIC ADAMS, NEW YORK MAYOR.
>> IT'S A NATIONAL PROBLEM.
WE MUST BE REAL IMMIGRATION
REFORM AND WE MUST IMMEDIATELY
HAVE A SHORT-TERM FIX MAKING
SURE THAT THE COURSE OF THIS
DOES NOT FALL ON THE LOCAL
CITIES.
>> Bill: THE CASE HE IS MAKING
IS NEW YORK CITY IS SPENDING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
NEW YORK HAS SAID WE'RE A
SANCTUARY CITY.
IF YOU WANT TO COME HERE, YOU
ARE WELCOME.
SO WHAT NOW?
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM.
NEW YORK CITY OPERATING AS A
SANCTUARY CITY, NEW YORK STATE
OPERATING AS A SANCTUARY STATE
HAVING THESE INCENTIVES AND
REWARDS IS SENDING A MESSAGE TO
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T YET IN THE
COUNTRY.
IF THEY CAN GET HERE AND MAKE
THEIR WAY TO NEW YORK.
THIS IS THE ENVIRONMENT WAITING
FOR THEM.
IT IS ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO JUST
GO THROUGH THEIR OWN PROCESS OF
COMING TO THE COUNTRY EVEN IF
IT'S ILLEGALLY.
SO I DO BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO GET
CHANGED.
AS FAR AS THE DRAIN ON
RESOURCES, WE SEE WITH SHELTERS
AND HOTELS AND SCHOOLS WITH
MEDICAL FACILITIES.
THE COSTS FOR TAXPAYERS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE HARD WORKING
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
ARE IN NEW YORK LEGALLY, IT ENDS
UP BEING UNBEARABLE.
THIS TRAJECTORY IS
UNSUSTAINABLE.
THE CITY AND STATE CAN DO ITS
PART BY REVERSING THE SANCTUARY
CITY POLICIES.
>> Bill: HE HAS HAD TOUGH
LANGUAGE FOR THE FEDS AND FEMA.
DID HE SAY PRESIDENT BIDEN BY
NAME?
>> IT'S A PROBLEM.
THE THING IS ERIC ADAMS, WHICH
CREDIT TO HIM FOR SAYING THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE ACTION AND
LEADERSHIP HERE.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT IMMIGRATION
REFORM, I DON'T THINK HE IS
TALKING ABOUT FINISHING
CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER WALL
OR ENDING CATCH AND RELEASE AND
FORCING THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY.
WE SHOULD BE BETTER SUPPORTING
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
USING THE TERM WE NEED
IMMIGRATION REFORM FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T MEAN
IT IS COMING WITH THE SPECIFICS
TO ACTUALLY SOLVE IT.
>> Bill: WE'VE BEEN THERE FOR
TWO YEARS.
OTHER MEDIA OUTLETS HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR THE PAST MONTH.
THE BUSES WORKED.
IT DREW ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE.
THE FLIGHT OUT OF FLORIDA TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD DREW ATTENTION
TO THE ISSUE.
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> 100% ABSOLUTELY.
IT ENDED UP ADDING PRESSURE.
MAYOR ADAMS, WOULD HE BE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER PUFFE
TTING E
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF NOT
FOR THE WAY NEW YORK CITY HAS
BEEN FORCED TO BEAR THIS BRUNT.
I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR BUSES AND
FLIGHTS TO COME TO NEW YORK
CITY.
THE FACT IS, ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN THIS WAS NOT JUST A FLORIDA
ISSUE, A FLORIDA -- A TEXAS
ISSUE, A TEXAS CHALLENGE AND YOU
HAD SOME OF THESE BLUE CITY/BLUE
STATE LEADERSHIP FORCED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO ENDED UP
CHANGING THE CONVERSATION AND
MEDIA IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK
CITY JOINING WHAT, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, FOX HAS BEEN ON
THIS FOR YEARS.
>> Bill: WE HAVE.
ANOTHER QUICK STORY.
A STUDY OUT OF CALIFORNIA LOOKED
AT 16 MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES.
THEY FOUND ASIAN HATE CRIMES IN
16 COUNTIES ROSE 164% IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF 2021.
WHAT'S THAT TELL YOU?
>> THEY ARE VERY FED UP WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
CRIME IS A TOP ISSUE FOR THEM.
WE WON IN OUR GUBERNATORIAL
RACE.
SUNSET PARK AND WE WON THE ASIAN
AMERICAN VOTE THEY ARE
PREDOMINANTLY DEMOCRAT.
WHY?
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY PUSHING
FOR N FRONT OF A SUBWAY CAR AND
KILLED.
BEATEN ON THE STREET WITH A
HAMMER.
NOT JUST AN ASSAULT.
WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR LIFE.
THE ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
NEW YORK CITY FELT LIKE AN
ATTACK ON ONE WAS AN ATTACK ON
ALL.
THEY FELT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WASN'T SERIOUS ENOUGH ABOUT
FIGHTING CRIME.
>> Bill: VERY INTERESTING.
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAI